il y a
ça ça veut dire oh oui oh là là c'est
bon oh là là oui c'est étonnant non
certains ont peut-être surpris de
trouver ici une émission consacrée au
film pornographique car vous avez une
activité que l'on connaît mal
que vous gardez un peu secret il faut
dire j'ai essayé jusque aujourd'hui mon
cher Claude donc c'est fini et qui est
le doublage de films pornographiques
nous avons vu tout à l'heure comment on
doublait les voix et les bruits des
acteurs
dans des auditoriums où on refait la
bande-son mais vous vous doublez les
films pornographiques pour les
non-entendants voilà pour les handicapés
en général et surtout pour les j'ai déjà
essayé pour les non-voyants mais c'est
plus difficile pas grand chose et pour
les non tendance c'est c'est une façon
de faire abruter au lieu de d'envoyer de
l'argent à la Pologne et n'importe où on
aide
les oxydants
comment devient-on doubleur de films
pornographiques pour non-entendants
c'est une excellente question
[Musique]
il faut quelques diplômes il faut le
baccalauréat bien sûr
il faut il faut plusieurs licences il
faut avoir été licenciés vraiment de
partout pour ça il faut une maîtrise de
genoux la maîtrise de genoux c'est
il faut également un certificat médical
il faut être en très bonne santé il y a
une gestuelle évidemment et notamment
une arthrite du coup par exemple ça a
l'air de rien mais avec une artère du
coup donc il y a certains gestes qu'on
peut même pas
on peut même pas faire donc il faut pas
avoir d'arthrite du coude
oui j'ai une très belle
et puis enfin il faut un certificat de
naissance alors c'est très spécial ça
certifié Alexandre avec leur exacte
votre naissance juste pour faire chier
c'est l'administration
maintenant
de de doublage pour nous entendre pour
des gens qui seraient tentés parce que
s'il y a des sourds qui nous écoutent ça
peut les intéresser alors il y a
certains gestes qui reviennent très
souvent par exemple ça
ça veut dire tu la sens
et l'immense affection que je porte
alors il y a
ça ça veut dire oh oui oh là là c'est
bon oh là là oui oh là là en quelque
sorte il y a un peu plus
ça vient c'est souvent ça c'est
du poulet ça se retrouve
quoi encore
ça surtout dans certains films
les coeurs d'armée rouge c'est bien ici
c'est rare mais c'est des films porno
machine à vapeur c'était content
il y a un geste qui revient aussi comme
ça
ça veut dire c'est bien ici chez Claude
Villers
et puis il y a aussi
[Musique]